gotta always split the square big week
for your boy dude it's a big week
of [ __ ] dude he's psychologists i don't
i need this negativity is that the theme
i'm i don't need your negativity brian
love today is some days
here's what it is some days you don't
want to fight you got to fight some days
you don't want to [ __ ] be funny you
got to be funny sometimes you want to
operate on a person and they're dying
because you're like my fingers are sore
i'm playing the piano all day and now i
got to cut into them how do i do this so
who are you when you don't feel like it
you got to be a gentleman when you don't
feel like a gentleman well that's it
guys that's right i need you i need you
i need you to chill out because it's a
big week for your boy it's a special
week my special drops on thursday
special i need you to be cool man okay
dude but i'm feeling real [ __ ]
prickly i'm a cactus i'm a man cactus
yeah i'm a mactus okay mactus yup i'm
all prickly
yeah well that'd be just cat man right
yeah pretty much cacti man it's cacti
cacti man i had a guy i got a guy cut
out i had a guy get out of his car and
run toward my car because i
i wasn't making a left turn uh
and and he was like the [ __ ] signal
and i and i was like the signal's not
changed yet hey he's freaking out and i
thought i was like i might get shot here
by a guy whose life is so terrible that
he's going to kill me because
you do you just kind of listen you
wouldn't go i was like waiting in the
wrong lane i guess this is according to
him okay
a little bit frustrating but i was like
please he didn't have to get out he
ain't got the guy he was so mad
he got out and he slapped he hit the car
no he started coming toward me but i was
like come on was he a big guy nobody
looks he looked like things weren't
going well for him and he looked so good
he kind of looked like he was that that
guy who at 40 years old realized oh no
i don't have a resume or anything going
on and i was like i think he's going to
kill me snapped yeah
i'm the guy who's going to snap on yeah
that happened sometimes you you could
have been that guy you could be that i
just saw that i just saw world star hip
hop some dude traffic stop they get some
little altercation over a parking spot
shoot them that's right no don't do it
dude
that was like a guy he was he's driving
a truck and i guess he was a good guy
but he [ __ ] he had a day he puts he
gets
there's a guy he's he he gets out of the
car to [ __ ] with the guy in the car
and he gets to the guy who's having a
day and what did he do he reached in and
grabbed the guy in the car and you know
what the guy did shot him right in the
chest
wait the dude that guy went to pull him
out yeah and he got shot yeah he was
really sad because his friends were like
he was the best guy he just had attacked
he just had a [ __ ] temper that time
can't do it oh especially on the [ __ ]
road
i assume everybody has a gun exactly i
want no she should
assume everybody you cut me off yep like
hey go ahead i don't know what you did
yeah i don't know what the [ __ ] cool
it's that muay thai guy he's like he has
a he had a muay thai school and uh
he was a badass and all his friends
there and guy was breaking into his car
so what did he do he's a fighter he ran
after the guy
cornered the guy and the guy shot him
killed him
you know sometimes it's like you know
it's not a lot of shit's not worth it it
ain't worth no like a little [ __ ]
like i'm not hold on you're gonna fight
over a guy making a wrong left yeah i
ain't doing it yeah we're gonna
literally hold up even there's no guns
like just say just
think about if he if he took the time to
get out his car how far will he go
well how far would he [ __ ] go but
think about that that's right another
human being in the stream oh yeah
i will say this there's one time where i
my baby was my my stella was like you
know a baby in in a chair and um my wife
and i time yep we're driving and this
and this [ __ ] um
semi
was on my ass like i can't tell you like
were you going slow though no no were
you in the fast lane no i was like i
don't know where i was but he was like
inappropriately tailgating too close
yeah yeah and i mean just with a baby on
board yeah but he was really semi and i
and i i i look back and i'm like and i
stick my finger out and he's he's doing
it more and i saw [ __ ] red and i go
i'm gonna you just [ __ ] fight this
guy and i followed him my mind was
telling me i followed him to a pit to a
uh truck stop with your kid in the car i
was gonna kill him i was i go i'm gonna
fight this guy
in a truck stop and i my wife and baby
and i get there and i i get to the the
pit stop and the guy gets out he doesn't
know he's just getting that he's just
yeah getting out he's walking typical i
see him he looks like he's he doesn't he
looks like kind of like a little bit
overweight big guy but overweight and um
and i i see him and then i'm i'm i'm
going to get out and i'm going to go
[ __ ] he doesn't beat him i think he
knew right he yeah probably just you're
going to mind you're rolling up like you
leave you're going to call him i'm going
to go back
yeah well now i'm saying they don't look
good but i mean truck truckers are tough
they're talking
from a trucking family
you're lucky that it wasn't my uncle
charlie my grandpa i'd be in trouble you
would have got oh my god all the
problems i'd have i have my hands full
they like the fights yep and then
at that point i was i was willing to do
it
but here's the thing so i
i don't have staying power i pull in he
gets out oh my god and i see two state
troopers walking they're walking this
way and i'm like you know
you know what it's a sign from god
that's god telling you not to do also he
i realized the guy was just a
just a guy yeah i don't think he was
being a dick
as a truck driver dude they that's all
they do
he's so bad and he's been on the road
for 18 hours
he's downing mountain dew no i'm [ __ ]
freedom no upside and then he's like did
you get the this pre um were you in the
prius yeah probably he even thinks he's
gay
and you're all uh
some of those drugs are like decked out
aren't they hell yeah somebody they have
like [ __ ] beds and all that [ __ ]
right yeah yeah
because they pull over and sleep with
them yeah
any time i've ever any time i've ever
gotten mad at somebody i've done
anything that outrageous i've regretted
the [ __ ] out of it
oh yeah yeah oh everyone does everyone
sometimes you don't want to yeah some of
those trucks are dope because you can't
sleep with them and then a lot of times
if depending on the route right i have
my black belt in trucking so anytime
they depend on the route they have a
like a partner so then they take turns
so one sleeps in the bathroom driving
yeah oh i thought they just did this at
all
hard it's a hard i don't have a partner
but they make good money sorta it's a
hard life man yeah that's that's a tough
one my grandpa was a businessman because
he was working for this trucking company
for years and then saved up enough money
and bought his own truck and when you
buy your own truck you bought another
truck then he had his own business so
some of those cats are like renting that
truck specifically my grandpa bought his
but usually you're working for a company
that provides the truck and you're just
doing oh gotta go you're working for the
man you're gonna have those trucks on
the road all day long you've got it and
they have to have [ __ ] buddies
marginalized the margins are versus oh
dude my uncle now charlie shout out to
charlie yeah you know
close uncle i've ever had we we grew up
with him he was the best but truck
driver you know military same as my
grandpa military then went into truck
driving you know even now he's a truck
driver right now he does the same route
i think from
uh denver
to uh
somewhere in missouri then through
kansas city and back
three times a week dude oh [ __ ] yeah two
three times five yeah yeah no his back's
all [ __ ] like dude yeah it's a beast
sitting down and just driving the whole
time yeah but you know who listens to
the podcast shout out to charlie him
oh dude down the road non-stop that's
right what else yeah what else can you
unleash so much music yeah so listen a
lot of podcasts
that's a [ __ ]
coming back from florida you got to take
two planes because you go for uh
to denver
by the time i'm off that plane
the layover it was the mass mandate
lifted but when you're flying
loved it left it i think it's funny when
you see videos like again if you look at
social media social media is upset we
need mat where's your math why are you
so mad but then also they they act like
you know everybody's against it have you
seen the videos of when they announced
mid-ear yeah mass mandates lifted yes
the stewardess the [ __ ] yeah yay
throwing them in the air and [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] why because why because i want to
cover my face all the time yeah
i i feel so claustrophobic for two years
i've been claustrophobic
and you know they're like sir you gotta
be drinking like no i got called out
yeah this guy goes sir i know what
you're doing yeah i was like huh yeah
well for la they were like you still got
to wear masks they even told us as we
were before like as we're getting ready
to land they're like okay we're headed
to how much how crazy but what's such a
powerful no but no one [ __ ] does it
that's what i heard no i know what i
heard no one puts up no i don't know
what walking around i didn't
yeah i don't care yeah but don't force
everybody to do whatever you see in
china what they're doing to the children
how they have them in complete covered
in in in suits with uh goggles and masks
and they take them away from their
parents
i don't know i just don't get it i don't
understand it's i'm i'm trying to like
understand like how the [ __ ] it like
how does how is that logical like i'm
just trying to understand it's what
happens when government has all the
power over you all the power yeah that
means like what it looks
[ __ ] some people up but also like
majority people it hasn't [ __ ] up but
but china i mean like uh an example they
want zero cases
but i mean
now with the the variance it's like the
flu we're gonna live with it people
that's what i'm saying around what are
you doing wants me an example yeah zero
cases so they think by doing these
horrendous lockdowns which we know for a
fact doesn't work do all this
crazy [ __ ] yeah that they can get there
and they're just ruining it
this is the most insidious part about
china you have a social credit score if
you want to get a loan if you want to
get an apartment or whatever if you have
been they track your phone if you have
if you are friends with or have spent
time with somebody who has a low credit
score you may not get that loan you may
not get that apartment so so what they
do just just because you hung out with
someone else yeah that means
if that was just never get a house my
friends are not
horrible credit all right all terrible
all mass psychosis what happens is
that's how you get that's how you
instill through technologies through
someone's phone that's how you instill
total obedience it's called
totalitarianism yeah yeah control over
the total person but here's what's crazy
you know they're so
uh
obviously they're super disciplined and
obedient there's so many people in china
if they just revolted let's say 10
revolt they couldn't do [ __ ] there's so
many of them yeah so if they went hold
up this ain't right they're taking our
kids killing the animals we can't leave
the house if if
20 was like [ __ ] this noise the law of
revolution starts now they start playing
[ __ ] rage against the machine and
[ __ ] storm everything china couldn't
do anything dude there's so many of them
yeah but they know that they have that
power and that's fear tiananmen square
was so they're putting their kids in
like full-on they're taking them away
from sir they're taking them away from
their parents they take them somewhere
else well
there's also husbands just trying to get
zero they show them grabbing them
pulling them in there and the wife's
begging him not to take him it's not
those dude that's [ __ ] crazy it's
crazy that's what governments do
that's why that's the extreme yeah but
it happened it would never happen but it
would never happen well don't say never
it happens one inch at a time it happens
one you give them a uh answer they take
a mile and then they'll never know it
could have been you'll never get the
power back yeah you will never get the
power back once you give it to them
you're never getting that that would be
tough to happen here we have too many
you got you got
guns too that's what i'm saying like you
got too many people that are like i
don't think i was like the amount of
guns that are out there that people have
like it's
that could never happen the the military
the the cops
there's no way it's the dark side of
technology though yeah
you can you can force people to do oh
speaking of dude yeah no doubt dude
sweet invisalign by the way uh you're
rocking him again which i appreciate
he's almost done he's almost done i mean
he's almost done
yeah
how many more i've got i've got exactly
seven more trays so wait it's different
raising the [ __ ] 70 days
oh
well that's forever
so we have 70 more days of this nonsense
well that's two months and 10 days you
know your teeth look that's hey
no hey hey
hey the bottom
uh-huh
i don't know i can't put a little tooth
whitener in there too i know
not great dude oh come on dude better
than mine i'll use
not great
those are straight as [ __ ] dude
i'll give you that better 70 days bro
yeah i'll tell you what one does it hurt
oh you got you got a whole situation in
your mind oh
first of all and i i made a promise to
my girl i'd get this done
uh you know with the special dropping on
thursday on think boy youtube thursday
morning you'll see me announce it on
rogan to blast that [ __ ] out and then i
come back home from austin for a day and
a half then i go to new york uh which i
won't be here next week you guys are
going to hold down the fourth we'll get
someone in my seat to carry the show but
um to be good ratings uh no i'm just
kidding no you guys are great
whoa
so i'll be in new york all next week
right and then i go to charlotte on tour
i'm there may 5th through the 7th comedy
zone get your ticketstickboy.com but the
thing is is uh when i get back and i can
finally chill out yeah i'm getting my
cavities fixed are you going to get it
done and i have such anxiety about it
but i'm going to go to your guy i'll
tell you who i'm not going to the guy
who cleaned my teeth and fixed the first
cavity okay did you feel it he had the
touch of charles man yeah
but i knew it was a problem goes you
used to be fighter right i'm like yeah
he was oh you take you get this easy
no [ __ ] no no no what what's fighting
have to do with you fixing my teeth
that's a that's a different yeah that's
it
he was pain
pain yeah you ready your mind he's got
needles in your mouth bro he was
so harsh dude he was not gentle dude
there was no luke there's no there's no
like the signal that goes from your root
in your mouth to your brain
it's not a long way to go yeah but uh i
would even be down to for like laughing
gas or whatever no you'll go doctor
shops has been doing it forever and if
anybody can keep you pain-free that
moment what is this and he's fast
he is from um
argentina or chile he's american he's
american oh god one of us yeah one of us
yeah yeah you don't want that [ __ ]
pain i'm gonna get back on my schedule
i'm moving against john john shops and
he's in uh he's in woodland hills how
many of you guys awesome
three three cavities it's the it's top
bottom the molars back there where daddy
likes to eat the sweets and then one up
here yep like we have donuts because we
have a photo shoot at this for a thick
boy yeah that drops tomorrow at nine a.m
so we're doing a photo shoot with the
donuts uh actually i'll try it i i
forgot i put it in what is this why does
candy do that to you though sugar cause
cavities right i don't know oh yeah i
don't know yeah
i can't eat any sugar no sugar no sugar
just hurts
like a noisy [ __ ] teeth really bad
what so the only foods you can take is
like like you can eat the meat that like
regular yeah that's thing that's why i
only certain foods there's something
yeah there's something it hurts sugar
hurts so bad dude
but that's also why i'm losing weight
i'm getting able to eat sugar so it's
kind of this that's how i was that's how
i always know i have a cavity if i eat
like something
all the time and now i haven't had it
when did we do tough mud i mean now
that was that that donuts the first time
that [ __ ] let me ask you this how
deep is that cavity that's going deep
right now you've been well he's probably
you know he's probably in a good spot to
where you don't have to get a root canal
no i don't when i was at the dentist i
here's my other thing clearly a money
hustle because you're in them this side
yeah you could have just done this side
and fixed them yeah because i want you
to come back in a few days bro i'm here
now you're never
you're never and that's what my girl my
girl goes you have to do it today to get
him in here was a nightmare like he
doesn't want to be here just knock it
out like oh so he fixed one so you see
how we work can you let's schedule
another appointment clearly a money plan
yeah yeah like why not just knock it all
out yeah somebody knock them all out
they did it and they were like you have
two small cavities back there really
small and then i was like oh can't i
just get a better toothpaste that's
going to fix them he's like they're past
that point yeah but they're not bad but
if you don't fix them you got to drill
you got to drill the decay out
oh that's going to be i've had a root
canal and [ __ ] that i heard that's
actually i didn't feel it at all why
you're you're under no he didn't put me
under but they gave me like the the
numbing [ __ ] so i didn't feel i felt
nothing i but i've whenever i get a
cavity filled oh i feel that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] hurts oh yeah doctor shaw
what'll he he'll do is that well
yeah
c-h-a-v-e-s
what he'll do i'll make a call i'll set
it up
he he will he will numb your gum before
he shoots before he did you know
that's the that's that's the best dude
that's a big deal that's the best it's
also two thousand they rub that [ __ ] on
yeah
yeah
dude it's also 222. do your tools have
to look like medieval execution yeah
do they have to be steel it's tough it
comes out of a steel car
and there's a [ __ ] all this crazy
still a manual process dude it's still a
manual process yeah
but some of those individuals are pretty
quick with it man if you get you got a
good guy that's good they're pretty
[ __ ] quick with it guy's the best you
promise or is he is he a buddy and you
just like no i mean he's been he's been
doing it he's got such a huge client
here's the other thing he doesn't need
the money he makes money yeah mm-hmm and
so what happens is he'll go he'll do
just as much as you need like he'll be
like i wouldn't do this right now
like yeah oh god yeah you know he does
not i've accepted my you go to certain
dentists they'll recommend 50 different
oh for sure it's awesome he goes he's
like no hold on hold on you don't need
to we're going to just do this yeah like
literally just enough he didn't do your
invisalign no yeah he did that's the
same guy i got to take the mold because
the first time i did that i didn't pay
attention and i didn't see yeah they
don't do a mold anymore artificial
intelligence does a laser they just
stick a camera oh [ __ ] they take a bunch
of pictures and then they just leave it
up they just go like this
oh they create yeah yeah yeah and then
they and then they come back with it now
now to get my teeth normal would be
three and a half years with steel braces
yeah this is like this is less than six
months does this hurt though
no you don't feel it at all because it's
like it's basically like shifting your
teeth right over time right just tighter
tighter yeah
and they have different levels for this
[ __ ] and that works faster than steel
braces i feel like braces are so much
faster like so much faster but is it the
accuracy of the braces like
better like like it'll fix them like
make it no this is sure this is
artificial intelligence now this is the
only way to go man if you're if you're a
parent and your kids in high school
especially now you have metal braces
like dude you're getting lit up but now
you could just rock those invisibles
right that's my daughter she's 14. she's
talking about it
that's what she'll do if she has to do
it she'll do the event just do the
bracing dude my brother jay had braces
for his teeth were so
[ __ ] up uh [ __ ] dude from like fourth
grade to 12th grade i mean it sucks i
mean he got roasted for all the time oh
yeah really roasted
[Laughter]
dude [ __ ] chin how about chin we're
doing the shop show i have luke thomas
one of my favorite people and i'm
signing off and chingos we you know the
team did something for you i'm like wait
what and what's happening and he plays
this video of my favorite people in my
life of comics people in the mma game
congratulating me on the the special
that drops thursday that was changing
you did that
chin's the best you son of a [ __ ] you
son of a [ __ ]
dude when i say i cried yeah oh i cried
he was he was balling
yeah well i came in hard i came in
and i go what's super hot what's wrong
with this oh what's that what's
happening oh i was i thought you rubbed
your eye or something
no i'm talking
snot bubbles
well your face was
this swollen red and your eyes were
like hell red i was like what happened
here what is he i thought you were
having an allergic reaction i couldn't
stop crying and you were reading your
teeth it's my favorite people in my life
you two theo chris eric uh john anik
schultzy chael sonnen
i mean everybody
dude my dad
my dad jay
my uh my girl and the kids
wow and this is what's funny yeah i was
crying and so i didn't want to make a
joke about it but my dad goes this is
the first of many
it's my second end
shout out to your dad
and the first one is show time papa and
here's the prom here's the problem it's
after i get done shooting my special you
you me you you didn't come the taping
which is fine i get it you didn't know
what you're signing up for and then you
come out the next week and what'd you
say to me
how'd your speech go so
he said first of many yeah my parents
would do that we're so proud of you
first of many
and even though i'm crying my eyes out
in my head i went wrong
and i i should light them up but i i'm
gonna yeah mama did mama no mama monet
didn't get in there she didn't get in
there
but jay did which is to have jay make a
video jay hates being he's so awkward i
know right but i started crying
dude he was hey and he's like being on
tour with you it's been so i'm like ah
[ __ ] dude yeah and then tiger's saying
you know good luck on the special papa
and boston saying that like [ __ ] that's
amazing oh it got me
oh he got me i bet it did man yeah all
my guys see how proud they are
pretty cool tough man that was all chin
all too it's not all me but
jin you i mean you coordinated it you
know yeah
my appearance
on there saying all great things then
he's like congratulations which is also
the name of my podcast
promo god dawg yeah you got it yeah i
was crying too man like
it's kind of crazy to watch that stuff
so it's casey yeah well they're all
crying yeah we're all in there this is
an emotional
yeah well what can you do it's hard
but it's also there's a lot of
it's not even pressure because you can't
do anything about so you you know when
you shoot a special you put any
creative material out it's like here you
go judge me
you know your fans are going to dig it
and then the recipe was here he goes
judging but it's also hard so it's hard
to come up with an hour it's hard to
come up with a half hour it's hard to
stand up it's hard to keep
it's hard to shoot a special and then
also have a good one and then also it's
edited right and looks how you want it
to look and then on top of that well
social media is really nice at least
yeah which you know i don't partake and
i don't subscribe to it but it's also
like
you know it's hard enough if it's on
netflix or hbo or showtime or amazon or
comedy central and i decided to make
go the hardest route and not go that
route which i could have that'd been the
easy way to do it and have my team shoot
and have it look exactly how i want to
look and then
bank on not having to publish this and
me just doing it literally all myself
and paying for billboards and all this
[ __ ] dude so it's like
hopefully it works out hey what can you
do speaking of which you're going to be
producing my special may not wait before
you read
your pet special that's not recorded yet
because my week though right
is my actual special descent drops this
you're talking about a lot on thick boy
youtube
chin
give them the sizzler do i have the
scissors yeah they're going to send it
to you okay so as soon as they send it
to me yeah
sizzle like the
so then we're coming back we just
watched the sizzle
and we're back does casey have it uh
hold on hold on say it again and we're
back
sorry hold on guys
you're crying
i mean it's good because brian got a
tear man i think brian has a little tear
you're so proud got a little tears
there's a baby bird you just see a
groove
boner
just your whole jeans sorry dude i could
turn why did you have to get into boner
i don't know
i get a boner when i watch
uh all right well listen uh brandon's
special it's out man that was the
brennan special section yup
of
course about himself
excuse me
oh my goodness you're going right keep
going you're gone
oh chappelle how was uh austin you heard
that was great yeah i had a good time at
moon tower yeah i did uh
quite a few shows my favorite spot uh
that that creek in the cave people love
it yeah it's it's a really cool room
there's there's uh i don't know there's
just a dope energy with doing shows
in austin couldn't live there i could
not live there no i don't like muggy
when you go in there you're like that
right yeah you go in there like could i
live here cause so many of our friends
live there and as soon as i touch on
like yeah it's on my mind the entire
time i'm like could i live here no i
couldn't i couldn't think so and that
sixth street is just [ __ ] because i
had to walk sixth street a lot yeah to
get to the shows and it was just so
[ __ ]
great oh my god especially me because i
don't drink so i'm like you and i are
the same man i don't like that [ __ ]
either oh gosh like i don't and i don't
like to like hang much or whatever like
i'll talk to people we're not really
festival guys yeah yeah i just don't
like to hang much you know like it was
but it was cool like doing the shows and
stuff like that you've done festivals
before though right mm-hmm i did uh uh
jfl new faces but yeah i was the last
one
but outside
uh comedy central clusterfest where was
the jfl the one in montreal i ran it to
you there that's right
he does not remember bro
but but you just said that was that that
was the the last time they had it there
was it was uh 2019. yeah they didn't
have it they didn't have it
back this year though put us back this
year yeah yeah i think vancouver and uh
montreal oh they're doing oh
both oh wow it was a good time when i
was younger to do that yeah yeah i had a
good time with that stuff you know i
like it yeah
it's it's fun man
it's good stuff let's take a little
break from chatting with chappelle and
the rinks
because you know what guys
i love this company you guys know this
it's how i got started on my biking
journey it started with me in a peloton
out of my garage i love peloton my name
on there's thick boy prez you can find
me on there your boy was putting in work
not like uh what if i went this and took
this to the real
world and brought it to the road and
then i started think boy bike club so
i'm forever grateful for peloton i'm
telling you man it's so much fun you can
do it from the comfort of your frickin
home man they have new classes new music
new ways to keep your workouts fun
motivating it's my favorite thing about
peloton because
it's was never the same workout there's
always something new new playlists i'll
do a 20 minute class a 30-minute class a
45-minute class 10 minutes and i would
bust my
booty on it and get such a good sweat
and now they have even more the pelton
plus dude they have boxing that's right
they have boxing and there's no gloves
needed it's from the same great
instructors that are running your biking
classes and uh it's a great workout
they're working on fundamentals you're
throwing fun combos overall it's fun
you're burning calories again one of my
favorite things about pelton is the
music pelton's adding fun new artist
series uh classes all right so whatever
you're into pop rock hip hop edm they
have over 100 artists series to choose
from so you can find your find your
favorite music and then you're just
grinding you're not even thinking about
all the cows you're burning the sweat
and climbing the hill or whatever you're
doing because it's great music man it's
easier to stick your goals when your
workouts are fun and interesting and
that's why i love peloton all right
peloton has a workout every day for
every schedule whatever it is long days
you got 30 minutes of stretch they have
20 minutes of cardio do a quick 15
minute total body class before you get
to work you got 15 minutes daddy come on
stay motivated while having fun with
bike workouts yoga meditation dance
cardio and boxing and more man visit
onepeleton.com to learn more that's one
peloton.com o n e p e l o t o n dot com
see out there
before we get back to the program one
more little ad for you guys today's
finally kid is brought to you by real
ketones and honestly guys you know we do
a lot of reads on here but honestly it's
one of the most incredible things i've
used you know i was the keto kid for
quite some time i'm the carnivore kid
all right so when you talk about health
all right and you and you want to feel
your best
i recommend you know being on a diet and
keto worked for me all right in keto it
can be tricky man to fall out of ketosis
and all that stuff you're trying to stay
in ketosis but
you listen the goal of keto it's pretty
simple the goal of keto is the
production of ketones you want your body
to burn
fat not carbs not sugar you want to burn
fats all right which happens naturally
in the liver that's what gives you more
energy
energy burns fat increases focus makes
you feel good overall all right but it's
tough to do if you're just on a diet man
it's really tough to do but the real
ketones make it so much easier they
automatically put you in ketosis so you
don't have to deal with all that stuff
and it does it takes out all the
guesswork they got you man it's
absolutely incredible uh you know it's
just it really works whatever your goals
are energy weight loss all right on any
diet hydration ketosis and whether
you're keto or not you don't that's the
thing you don't have to be keto real
ketones and bhp needs to be part of your
daily routine take from your thick
friend up here i recommend the shift all
right with your keto or not this is the
best product to try to feel your best
100 of the time it comes in five
delicious favors all right my favorites
the dark uh i think it's black cherry
it's fantastic it's delicious take it
from your boy here man if you're trying
to stay on diet trying to lose weight
just overall feel good you can be a
thick boy but be a healthy thick boy
have energy stay on a diet that's going
to help you out man get it right now at
real ketones dot com use the promo code
shop s-e-h-a-b for 10 off if you don't
love this product they give your money
back that's how sure we are you're gonna
love it and you're gonna be in great
shape you're gonna feel good you have
energy all right that's real ketones dot
com shob use promo code shop sch aub for
10 off that's real ketones dot com slash
shop it was the uh but those shows like
yeah the energy of those crowds man
you know i think there was probably one
show that i was like eh
but they're like
yeah they were just good shows and
performing at that
uh there's this other spot that gary
clark jr i guess is like co-owner or
something like that of uh called antones
it's like kind of like a oh that's a
good place rogan does it there too or he
used to do shows out there right yeah
it's kind of it's kind of like a little
like a smaller rock venue yeah but it's
actually but it's actually dope is it
cool oh yeah it was it was
electric
i liked it a lot i've heard some i've
i've gotten there a couple times oh yeah
yeah yeah but the austin itself
the crowds are great
crowds are amazing but i don't yeah i
just don't know but i can't connect with
it but i think too chappelle like when
you talk about living there like could
you live there i also think
if you judge it based off sixth street
and doing a festival it's tough it's
like if you came to l.a and you went to
sunset like i can't live here i couldn't
either if i came to sunset but if i
started exploring and you know if you go
to
lake travis and lake austin and you're
outside of there that's fair but i used
to live in texas
but not austin i lived in dallas yeah
different animals but yeah different but
i guess just for me it's just the
weather
yeah i just i just couldn't get down
with the weather it reminds me hot and
it reminds me too much of like home and
i left home to like mesa you know yeah
not mesa itself but phoenix with phoenix
itself just to like
i'm like man i worked my ass off to get
out here yeah you know what i mean so
it's like it's
it's simply too hot yeah and there's
just a lot of things about it that
remind me starting now until
not to disrespect too much what did you
say starting now until september it's
too hot
i mean i've never actually experienced
that kind of hop because that's you'll
get hot too this is humid like beyond
like i just no i mean listen
nowhere's been
hotter on this [ __ ] plant than we're
in oklahoma city that oh brother in june
same same area
oh you know unplanned and mark harley's
just running three miles into the savage
i was like what he's like well i'll meet
you back at the hotel and just start
running right up and it's june
for a guy that big that he can run that
far is crazy oh it's insane [ __ ] nice
like he ran through and we just got done
eating he was savage we ate
if you cut his hair off he would get
really skinny
it's a samsonite chili's heel i know i
want to see what's short here i scare
him with shields because obviously it
used to be that way yeah no it was a it
was a bit of a pompadou a pompadou yeah
it was a papa dude he hit it all like
no you used to have a straight up short
hair oh really yeah because he was a
substitute teacher and he couldn't have
long hair so really he had short hair
isn't that funny he was a substitute
teacher yeah
and a tutor
yeah
yeah
yeah mark's wicked smart wow he's
insanely smart yes he is yeah catches a
lot of people off guard too mm-hmm
we were like oh wow he's actually really
he's a wild boy dude tutor yeah he's
gonna be a tutor hey can we watch your
sizzle now sure is that cool hit it go
ahead all right mike just said it over
so that was a fake we're back then and
we're gonna keep that word back we
should keep it as real as always
have it ready to go because guys i
always say keep it real no i'm the only
person in my house who don't speak
spanish my white friends aren't a latina
before i go dude just [ __ ] learn
spanish but little effort and learn
spanish how hard can it be my [ __ ] i am
38
i struggle with english at times
like my women like my check so make sure
that it's dead keep it real and make
them stand out like comedienne
boys goes dude
deal with a latina bro you know why
because they're fun and they're spicy
you know what spicy means they're
[ __ ] that's what that means
i decided to go on a keto diet you know
what keto is keto is a diet where you
can't eat mexican
food mama what are you doing i know you
know i'm on keto lebron look i'm doing
mosquitoes it's keto [ __ ]
we need bean cheese bean cheese bean
cheese green cheese we're just gonna
carb load year round results will be
built like armadillos you should know
about data mexican nobody told me this
there's many flaming hot cheetos all
over your house
[Music]
i've seen that [ __ ] sizzle
too many times
yeah i can't wait now and it crazy
watching yourself nothing worse
i can't that's the other shitty part
about doing your own spell you got to
edit all that [ __ ] with the team you got
to sit through that yeah oh i i actually
have uh need to see if the therapist if
i went to a psychiatrist which i
wouldn't i would say why wouldn't you
why can't i i'm kidding i mean i would
but i would say i can't figure out why i
am
physically almost physically
unable to
like yourself watch myself promote i
think most people i hate it so much you
had to for your
no you have to it's part of the game
yeah i don't i will you know you know
what kind of narcissist you have to be
to enjoy like
i even if i was in batman i wouldn't
like bring my family like let's watch
this somebody's different because you're
being you're you're critiquing yourself
or you know trying to like navigate what
fits best so i think it's different like
yeah like yeah first for stand-up
whereas like yeah batman i wouldn't have
my [ __ ] i don't know if i could sit
through and watch that what's his name
uh patterson
robert robertson he showed up at some
movie theater in burbank and sat down
watched it no [ __ ] which as a fan but
holy [ __ ] it's batman but also what are
you doing
what's he i guess that's probably the
way he wanted
like the vibe
he might be like oh let's see what
people like a lot of people most people
do that actually believe it or not most
actors will go to a movie theater and
watch the movie because a lot of times
you don't you you get invited to the
premiere but if you don't if you're not
you couldn't make the premiere for
whatever reason yeah you're gonna go see
it the vermeer is probably a different
watch too whereas like if he's just
watching it with just maybe he didn't
see the cut like the final cut so he's
like yeah let's see what what they did
with it yes yes okay i could i get it i
told you
there are a lot of examples like frank
willow was saying when he did minority
report
this is so long ago but he was like well
that's forever 37 yeah this well this
was tom cruise a minority reporter this
was 20 years ago yeah and but it was his
first big thing i get that it's like a
big job right we were like and and i
mean i remember him saying dude i got
i'm [ __ ] i'm working with tom cruise
i go you are yeah i i've got all these
you know and it was such a big deal and
i was like dude you've arrived this is
it this is it
and um
you get to the movie
you get to the movie theater nobody
tells you anything
okay and then you go like this with that
as far as cutting it i went to see my
boy yeah i was so excited right and he
saw the way they cut the movie and he
goes it like about 10 minutes in the
movie or 15 he goes he i think he said
oh no i wasn't with him but he's really
in it
he's not in it
he's in a helmet and you just see him
lean over and go like this
that's it
now adrian brodie same thing when he was
in the thin red line he brought his
whole family yeah and adrian brodie
pretty established actor yeah terence
malek never told him he was cut out of
the movie
he gets there and he's in like i think
in one tiny scene
so you well that happened you think it's
time
your wife at the time were sitting there
and you didn't know and then
what was i remember that oh yeah yeah
that was uh the movie i was in yeah yeah
oh yeah we you know we because you shot
out for wheat i know and then they
barely they he we don't know that it
really there oh where was i in one tiny
scene where you see like you see this
back of you and you say something like
come on yeah that's it that's that's it
i'm in the suit see you later i'm gonna
you said it for weeks oh yeah dude well
i'm bragging about brian but then you
get eating
like in in joker i i said i said to tom
to todd i go i go come over here for a
sec
i'm not gonna make it in this movie huh
he was like i mean he started laughing i
could tell i was like
this is not going to fit i was like
there's no all the stuff i'm doing this
is not going to fit it's story wise i
could just i've been doing it so long
you just felt you knew it's like i'm
here for five days it's not gonna yeah
yeah
it's fine but that's that's why doing a
film is always dicey yeah i mean
unless you're like the lead yeah you
don't have yeah unless you're leonardo
dicaprio yeah then it's like oh you're
[ __ ] yeah then you know yeah you know
what's up i'm taking the family of
premiere and even then you're gonna be
if you're like in a big part of the
movie
they might use takes and angles that
just make you look so [ __ ] bad
different or shocking
this weekend i only go to movies now if
it's a kids movie which is kind of a
shame but i did thank god
now because the pandemic they force the
movies to go to theater now first but
then it comes to on demand pretty fast
thank god is it yeah the turn around two
young kids it's great yeah it's [ __ ]
great but we went to uh the bad guys
mark mark marin is the voice of the
snake in it like no wow he's the main
right
it's him and then i forget the lead guy
who's the the the wolf on it it's called
the bad guys it's [ __ ] it's good and
a little cartoon movie it's cartoon oh
okay it's really well done it's like i
also appreciate like pixar that's not
pixar movie but like pixar and those
other movies that will have references
just for the parents because they know
that yeah you have to sit through it too
yeah so they kind of make it at least
keep your attention yeah otherwise i was
like my head i'm thinking this is like a
kitty movie i should just bring earplugs
and listen to [ __ ] podcasts or books
that's what i do it's because i'm gonna
sit there that's right
i put my earphone i can't no and it's
weird i do it
but it's even at my son at six it's
where he's gonna sit down watch the
whole thing like he moves around he'll
be like dad i'm tired let's get in i'm
like he's like yeah i'm just sick of
sitting down
bad guys dude he was locked in it's a
long movie too movie and i'd be like hey
dude you're good he's like yeah like oh
[ __ ] all right yeah you like that movie
yeah it's good it's [ __ ] good i
enjoyed it um
that's dope yeah okay all right we got
chin all right all ready okay all right
have we not been gone yeah but you know
some days some days we is it hot in here
yeah it's very that's why i open the
door because it's yeah i know i know
outside it's supposed to be like 93
today oh [ __ ] oh yeah you're going to
sleep
you don't you don't look at the weather
uh i actually had to cover up i got a
tattoo i'm working on my slime oh yeah
yeah
yet
yeah yeah yeah i want to show you i want
to see the final product yeah yeah i
don't see it yeah yeah i think kyle or
no that's this thursday kyle's going to
see our boy dan smith oh he is oh he's
like this would be his first one huh
yeah i wonder what he's gonna get he's
gonna cry oh for sure tattoos hurt they
hurt they're so bad yeah i know when
people that don't have tattoos and they
ask me i gotta hurt
her i don't know anybody who who like
i've only really heard it right my
brother's that kind of way who enjoys
the pain but other than my brother
from girls out here
like girls like i don't i i kind of
enjoyed it too now i'm a baby i don't
know what it is the first one get it
done though cat this last one this last
one i got on my arm so it's like a whole
sleeve she has a sleeve now which is
crazy i have an outline of sleeping
areas
they colored in the main piece and now
they need the backgrounds but but all
that the outlines yeah the outline oh
damn you got the whole arm done that's
pretty good the outlining is the worst
part well for me oh i think the shading
the shape oh i love the shading all the
shading shading is good for me outline
it's so weird that you like shading but
then how long were you sitting down how
many hours down about
i was there from nine to six p.m
the stencil took about like an hour to
put on also do that before i get there
though you know like you know i'm coming
on yeah yeah but you know when you get
there and like what's up man how are you
going to appoint my working on the
computer 7 p.m i'm like yeah let me just
draw it up real quick it's like
but i made this appointment months ago
right so you could have that done so i'm
not sitting here while you draw you
could have done that so when i get here
we can start some of the pros
dan dan was quick hey whatever happened
to that guy who got in trouble for that
killing me he's oh [ __ ] yeah he posted
are you he he commented
uh videos yeah you know daniel silva the
best one of the best dude his work is a
freak so when he was on a show oh wait
so he got out yeah he was on uh that ink
master incredible that's what it was but
uh yeah i think he apparently got out
because he's just posting dope work now
it's so good i mean it's insanely he did
the panther here okay
he's so talented wow yeah it's
incredible so he's i guess whatever
happened happened right yeah
yeah i mean it's a tricky case right
because
he tells the guy he's drunk because like
i'm drunk they [ __ ] rock paper
scissors who's gonna drive which which
friends do yeah we do that he drives you
get a horrible accent that guy dies
you know obviously you have to take some
responsibility but if we both engage in
god we're both drunk oh he's so talented
dude this is it it's incredible his
specialty is you see how the eyes are a
different color everything's black and
white but the eyes are colored that's
what he specializes in makes it pop yeah
i didn't do that with mine i was going i
don't want your specialty just do it
black
yeah he's so good oh he's and he's young
right there oh look at that wolf yeah
yeah see how it's like all black and
white and then like just certain colors
really stick out amazing
yeah if he could just show the other so
now wait when he's doing that as i'm
watching yeah is that he's that's
puncturing your skin yeah yeah yeah
that's puncturing your skin and putting
the ink in the skin oh yeah yeah
wow and that's how that's the part
depending on the tattoo artist like dan
smith's probably the best i've ever had
where it really didn't hurt yeah
are like heavy-handed some people are
some people heaviest hand yeah but then
also
um
your body releases natural uh
painkillers and endorphins for like i
think it's five or six hours because
i've had um on this sleeve here with
freddie negrete at shamrock social club
where i'm sitting there for over five
hours and eventually your body goes
we're all out poppy so it's going to
start to hurt and yeah it's
horrible where you're like you're so
aggravated but you want them to finish
like dude just hurry the [ __ ] up and
then when they how much you know how
much
are you doing again you're good for a
little bit yeah because the body you
know it adapts to it and it
slows everything down but eventually
your body goes all right dude we've had
enough daddy
and then yeah some areas like bleed a
lot some don't like my buddy my buddy uh
came out with me and my mother he had
his entire back done
and he passed out at the [ __ ] table
oh yeah he went like that if you if you
don't he went like this
yeah yeah if you don't eat your body was
right there he was he was uh she was
drink like orange juice or like you know
something if you have food and like
orange juice help you out i had a guy
come to my show and he's like hey man
you're talking about pains of tattoos
he's like you haven't felt [ __ ] and he
has like short shorts on his this and he
has he's covered from facebook oh
connect those toes and he's saying
inside here
he's like he's i think i'll just pitch
my neck down my ribs my sternum my
throat he's like there's not a pain in
the world than here and i went but why
would you do that
nobody sees it dude i guess you're a
girl okay why would you do that
unless you're in the yakuza and you're
gonna chop your pinky off if you don't
do it yeah why did you do that sir yeah
i just kept going oh i'd never do that
i'm never gonna feel that i love that
style of tattoo though yeah the japanese
it's so dope but i would never get
the very top of my inside of my front
door just think about just my pinching
like barely pinched there but also you
[ __ ] hurt but also you tie your nuts
and root down like i
can see that he needs the space he needs
room so you're going to have to oh like
oh you're saying
their tattoos and their bodies are sick
they're i think they're usually dragons
or something kind of yeah like that
entire body
who did yours cat
uh her name is gloria from highland
tattoo she's dope
my most recent tattoo artist both
predominantly speak chinese so they
really don't chat with me they just
can't tell me yeah look at these guys
which is nice because i'm in a lot of
pain i'd rather not i don't want to talk
these guys are hardcore [ __ ]
yeah it's it's all over your body it's
so dope though like all those crevices
imagine there's there's some guy in san
francisco who specializes in this and
he's like a six-year waiting list yeah
uh san jose yeah yeah dude look at that
it's state of grace
look how good that is i know it's so
nice but oh the the work is [ __ ] they
also have such a big canvas to work on
so so the when you give a tattoo artist
a real small tattoo they're like come on
dude right you know it's a beast for him
but this dude dude that ass that [ __ ]
you do might think about getting your
[ __ ] ass dude you do my brown ring
dude
yeah and girls do too
[Music]
yakuza
yeah that guy yeah it looks pretty sweet
which guy this guy i don't know man
damn it's just like how can you imagine
getting tattooed in there that's just
japanese gangster go to that race
but it also takes how many hours like
that's years and years and years let's
get that to go back because they're not
yeah that dude's a real [ __ ] deal
right back in the day that's an old
school [ __ ] that looks like you
in five years look at his hair
in five years
yeah if i shave my chest
if your hair goes that's you
had it up bigger ears just tatted up a
tan brian callan right you don't you
don't have any desire to get any tattoos
like no [ __ ] can you actually do
that this year
i guess i could do that that might make
sense
just do it i just feel like i'm probably
getting on your lower back just a tiny
one right you do a [ __ ] stamp dog
that'd be cool yeah dude get a barbed
wire on your arm
don't get that though
not that
i mean if i got something i want to get
that guy the butt that guy down there no
no we don't have time for that no no no
hands on his head hands on his head
right there that guy
oh thank you that guy right no that's
not for you b look at that it's color
too which is right well dude for so just
a spitball in here that probably took
over 120 hours i bet right oh that's
some hours especially look at the color
not that how long would it take
so long really
yeah
that's that's small this is with no
color how about that
i mean like
[ __ ] six eight eight like hours dude it
takes them forever like this was done in
pieces
over months so that takes forever that's
a crazy commitment but toby just got his
head done not so he got the top of his
head yeah well all those guys are here
travis
because he wants his whole body covered
right yeah hold the he'll bring him to
the crib and have two tattoo artists
we're going at the same time
two of those so one's working on the
right side one on the left once we're
down the arm the other's around the leg
and just
yeah just getting blasted
that's the term we use for getting
tattooed bro
the legs are intense too
old
i don't know if i want my legs down i
saw you get that that one where it was
just uh don't let don't don't let me be
the like marker because i do not do well
with it
though when you guys i just cried the
lego piece yes you said that one was
like don't hurt yeah i'm on the front
the shins like i figured because it was
dead from fighting from kicking yeah no
dude
it hits the bone yeah i don't know if i
can say it shivers through your body ah
[ __ ] that bad 100 on the legs
uh not as bad as my ribs but you
probably like a six or seven yeah ribs
are done i did acupuncture on my back it
hurt like a [ __ ] like they stick
those needles all the way in your body
and i was like oh my [ __ ] god really
right dude i thought it wouldn't be a
thing it hurt like maybe you've died
you've done it you've done it
how many times
i was bleeding too i was bleeding but i
didn't feel that stupid sometimes that
cupping if they suction it too hard it
will [ __ ] hurt me because the skin
goes
yeah what does that [ __ ] do what is it
covering it it gets the blood flowing
and gets all the toxins out of that one
place so let's say like when i tore my
hammies it was the top of my hamstring
that popped yeah so there's all that
like bruising and all that [ __ ] in there
so it sucks all that out and tries to
flush it out to bring new blood in there
yeah it helps that's why you see so many
fighters or boxers olympic athletes any
athlete with like dots all over the back
yeah it actually it actually works yeah
yeah 100 i believe in it yeah it helped
my hamstring it helped me a little bit
yeah yeah
i usually trust what athletes do if they
do it over and over olympic ethics
always do cupping yeah so ufc too that's
why you see all those weird dots like a
weird [ __ ] giraffe yeah it's so
strange acupuncture works oh you know
what i watched on uh netflix it's
[ __ ] good too is the john wayne gacy
files
they just came out yeah dude it's so
dark dude yeah that's great it's so well
done so you know the number one watch
thing on netflix last year
this shows you how weird to go hold on
hold on
the number one thing on number thing
richard
hold on that was a big one but no um
you're on the right track but then think
about they had narcos they have [ __ ]
ozark they have stranger things the most
watched thing on netflix was it my
terrible roommate nope but that's what
that one's good and that came out this
year but i like where your head's at
your character
was it uh true crime files or whatever
it's called that one's awesome
i love that show but it's it's it's a
documentary uh no it's a serial killer
from london
nope that one's so boring don't [ __ ]
with cats
no that was two years ago but i like
where your head's at okay last year hold
on
hold on hold on i think i you know come
on i think serial killer famous oh uh
donald hansen ted bundy
ted bundy tapes because what's dope
about netflix is like with the john
wayne gacy files they have files on
there that have never been heard and
it's him talking in prison and his
lawyer talking how he confessed him
before all this came out it's
sos that dude was horrible horrible
horrible and then he was also like the
life of the party he was in chicago and
then you'll notice like
there's some themes where we've learned
how to deal with these terrible people
where
you know this was in the 80s so in the
80s remember ted bundy's popping well
why did 10 buddy get away for so long
because back then
you know he was killing that network
well but also he was killing women that
were like hookers or whatever and
society really was like uh whatever they
looked down
look into it with john wayne gacy who
was he killing gay men young gay men i
thought he was saying boys
teenagers and and teenage and men but
all gay and a lot of them were outcasts
and like runaways
so society
yeah it was we're in a different time
now so they were killing people that no
one really gave a [ __ ] about so the mil
the the police force didn't put any
effort into it so they got away with i
mean casey they think over 50 murders
in his [ __ ]
basement
it's nuts
and then also what you'll see with like
the night stalker ted bundy
um not so much manson but with ted bundy
the night stalker and john wayne gacy is
they would kill in different areas and
the police precincts in those areas
didn't communicate there's this weird
eagle thing so
the night crawler got or the night yes
the night stalker crawler has a great
movie with nightstalker got away with it
because he would kill in burbank then
come to la so the burbank would have a
horrible murder that was the exact same
as hollywood but they would never they
would never share
info so then once they finally did
that's how uh uh
they're like hey we have this murder the
exact well we have that too and then oh
we have that then we and then they
realized there's that pattern and then
john wayne gacy also similar to btk
killer i'm way too into circulation but
similar to btk killer where he was
you know the guy of the
the city like in chicago
right for kids he was a clown but that
to me like
he never had to make his living not that
way yeah yeah no he was he he was he uh
oh he owned a construction company so
and then people would always go he's
[ __ ] those young boys he only hires
handsome young boys
which he was he was killing them that's
why she would want to have sex with him
but then pr if they would have talked
they would have realized that
before he moved to chicago he's in the
suburbs outside chicago he went away for
sodomy
with a with a [ __ ] kid dude he was in
prison supposed to get 10 years for good
behavior they only gave him 18 months so
he got out of there look at this and
then [ __ ] went to work he worked he
did a
were they embalming you know where they
take the body and they embalm it he
slept in a cop behind the embalming room
how uh jesus
he observed morticians embalming dead
bodies but when you watch it you're just
like holy [ __ ] dude it's so dark and the
way you kill people it's just so dark
sticking with strangulation
so he put he'd do a trick with him
he'd show them him getting out of
handcuffs like let me see you try it and
they'd be drinking stuff like that and
they put them on and then like all right
get them off i'm like nope and then you
kill him
he'd torture him yeah yep it's [ __ ]
nuts so he did some of the clown stuff
and obviously that's what american uh
horror
emphasized and that's where a lot of
stuff comes from but the kid stuff he
just did it because he said as a clown
like he could grab women and be mean to
kids because he goes clowns get away
with everything but it really it's not
really a narrative to set up for him
chilling okay so
teenage like and boys and men who are
getting runaways run away like okay yeah
yeah outcasts
in the 80s
you're looking at 50 people dude
and dude
he was such an [ __ ] when he they they
gave him the electric chair right and uh
they they have him on file saying this
his lawyer goes in there and he's like i
figured he'd be shaking his boots like
and the the prosecution was in there too
and they're like we figured he'd he's
he's gonna die
and he was so like
chill
and he he had such an ego thought he was
always right and he was he he did have
good leadership that's why he tricked
everybody and he uh told the prosecution
they go you have anything to say and he
goes the he was i got 50.
the state of uh illinois you're only
getting one just me he goes john still
wins
and then
and then bob
died an extreme narcissist
that's insane extreme right
you know what the audience is
that is
you know what they say about the state
of illinois you only got one he goes
john's still on top yeah 49. do you know
what they say about people like that who
are extreme narcissists like that those
total sociopaths yeah they can't believe
they got caught they they they don't
believe it till the very end like
they're like you know and and even then
he was like i still want oh even dude
you mean they're shocked that they got
yeah yeah they never think but when they
get convicted they're like they go like
this
what yeah they can't believe it's
happening to him but also he so he
killed one guy
it was never his fault right he never
took ownership of course not but when he
killed the first guy he said the kid
can't the kid i don't know he's by 21
let's say yeah but it was the first time
and he's married with kids at this time
john wayne casey was married with kids
yeah he had kids yeah oh holy [ __ ] yeah
and then got divorced and then this kid
still married yeah oh yeah he never saw
him after the first time i went to
prison but the first murder
he according to him and nobody believes
it but the first murder he said
they both went to sleep in separate beds
he wakes up and the the guy had a knife
and was trying to attack him so he
killed him he was like holy [ __ ] because
he was a democrat and did all this
fundraising all this [ __ ] and he's like
i i don't know what i don't call the
cops this looks terrible he goes so i
hid the body underneath the house
few months years go by and he's like
nobody has [ __ ] said anything oh i
can get away with this and he liked the
thrill of it and then just kept getting
away with it and even dude even when he
was [ __ ] being questioned everything
he thought he was so much smarter than
everybody
he thought he could even finagle his way
out of that of course like talk himself
out of it of course
yeah there's that whole they're all it's
about yeah it's about power wanting
power over another human being another
life
because he would god you get to play god
dude so he would hire a lot of like
prostitutes and like street walkers and
he'd go
i don't view them as people i would you
know i'm renting them for a half an hour
or an hour i can do whatever i want
that that's how he like because human
beings are objects they're objects
for his they're not
they're
and he goes and also look nobody look
how long i get away with it it proves
that so he would count so you would rape
them first and then kill him yeah or was
it the other one well you know
you know this is the necromancer did you
ever see how
he would kill him also if let's say this
can be a weird comparison but let's say
you're a streetwalker i pick you up and
you're like all right forty dollars for
a [ __ ] so we drive ooh yeah but let's
say you were into it right you're like
hell yeah 40 bucks and then we do it
and
and i and i give you 40 dollars you go
damn no tip
i can't get 20 for [ __ ] sucking on
the nuts
and then that would piss john off and
kill you over that yeah like so that's
what he would oh sometimes sure
well you know you know so he was just he
was just a closeted gay man
yeah
you're talking about already hated being
you're talking about a rare predator
social though
you know when they were when they were
stopping those migrant buses and because
they found out that they some of the
rival cartel members were on those buses
i don't know if you know this story the
zeta so they would they would pull them
off they'd check your phone and if your
phone had messages on whatsapp to like a
rival cartel guy they would take you if
you were with your family they'd kill
your family and then they take you and
they pit you against another guy on the
same cartel you both get hammers or you
get a knife or you get just your baby
you fight a fair one whoever and whoever
wins that fight gets recruited you kill
that guy and they be like all right
you're you're over here now you want to
die you want to be on our side that's
nice for the most people that's how they
would [ __ ] hand that yeah that's
legit fighting change that's why they
but they kill your family regardless oh
yeah that's i'm really crying but at
least i can kill you
but also if you kill my family just kill
me dude i'm not fighting exactly yeah i
just take them and shoot me like you're
going to kill my family let him do it
you took my family kill me let him agree
that's okay but that's what they were
doing then not to get so dark and we'll
transition from that there's also a doc
on there about abercrombie and foreign
watch that bro i i i was they went we
had nothing to do we went a little over
there we had nothing to do how to make a
billion dollars by by just being
straight up racist as [ __ ] because our
first oh [ __ ] for real because at first
she's how big abercrombie is when we
were coming up yeah so at first i was
like oh there's some woke agenda thing
so i came into it being like oh this can
be some [ __ ]
and then it gets a little dicey like
they're crushing it right and then they
create this shirt i don't dude how
stupid is they have this shirt it's an
asian themed shirt for a laundromat and
it was their number one seller it said
two wongs don't make a white
yeah and that it takes two longs to make
a one this is a legit shirt yes and we
didn't realize it oh no they realized
wait wait bring up they got in trouble
yeah you guys see that set off the
alarms and then also
you see but this is where i'm like
i guess since you're a public company
but
you remember abercrombie would have like
those models out front with their shirts
off and you're like jesus christ dude is
it this they're dying pieces
so guys they're they're girls but so
good looking i know but my thing is well
especially back then like
if your thing is to sell that
you're not going to want bad looking
people right no it was genius no no
don't get it wrong they they knew
because they saw ralph lauren they said
people can't afford ralph lauren but
people love everybody loves there's
something bring up the ads bring up the
models everybody loves
the the idea of this blue blood blonde
all-american ivy league all-american
there's something that's so out of reach
it's this it's just
aristocracy and it was it was like this
is the this is the whitest richest most
beautiful people they could find and
they were young and gorgeous and it was
all gay men it was all gay because the
owner and the photographer who was the
creative wallet we're so gay
like if you if you ever if you watch any
of their marketing like even when i
remember when i was younger in high
school abercrombie was popping yeah i
walked by the store i'm like how gay is
this yeah like how did we not realize
this back look at all the bruce weber
photographs he's a genius bruce weber
was also gay got in trouble during the
me too movement actually huge trouble
yeah but he was he settled but he's a
great photographer
great photographer if you're into guys
he's fantastic yeah it was they would
get they would get jobs
they were working so gay
oh well look they just get like these
jocks and they just have them like
posing it but then
these are supposed to be straight dudes
yeah like look at that look at that go
away go back wait so that's that's
actually bruce that's him yeah yeah but
that's him but he's so talented go go
look go up there but he's he's a gay man
yeah that's one super gay oh he is the
women
which one
there was it was the one that was
another
shower yeah and he'd have him just
moving around yeah do some wrestling
wrestle around but i i sort of got i'm
trying to be funny i remember in high
school i'd walk to that store and tell
my friends that's jeremy bloom that's my
buddy oh really yeah i played football
with him oh my [ __ ] really yeah yeah
he's su did i meet him you met him abby
kenny that's him yeah he wanted a stud
you said he said jeremy
did he play for the philadelphia and
look at the one on the beach ball and
then of course in
this kid played pro football and was an
olympic skier as well and he looks like
that yeah yeah and he made a lot of
money he was a business guy right now
he's a business guy in uh silicon valley
making all the money i mean what the
[ __ ] this kid's such a winner
i mean and he was doing he said he's a
sick athlete he wasn't that much bigger
than me by the way oh you waste one year
i mean much shorter than you yeah just
and then also ran like a 43 in the 40
and then it was olympics here he's the
kid where he kind of changed the rules
because they said hey if you're me in
the olympics he had like oakley and nike
and abercrombie and they went hold on
you're getting all these endorsements
then you can't play football
remember he was the one they didn't let
play oh my god yeah so he went to the
olympics and then still got drafted by
the philadelphia that's good yeah he was
good enough to play pro football yeah he
was a he's a free i mean he didn't last
in the league but still had a shot a god
and an olympic athlete on campus think
about this he's a tommy hilfiger model
so no girls girls didn't like him at all
dude he was tom cruise on the [ __ ]
campus
and just like a normal dude like yeah
really nice guy yeah damn but
abercrombie fitch they got really dicey
when they they they started figuring out
like there's a black girl on there
there's a filipino guy they weren't
giving them hours but they didn't fire
and they were sending out they just
pointed them out they were like they
were like it's too asian they were
saying this out they were like literally
emailing the guy mike jeffrey's just
doubled down he was just that guy was
like gay photographer yeah and he was
like now i just want really hot white
people basically but these are gay men
yeah super gay they were trying to [ __ ]
all the models and they did not they're
gay in races well i mean what for them
they were like look what's selling
trying to pitch gorgeous blue blue
blonde-haired blue-eyed guy and they
would say they would have they so
you want to work in their stores
documentary's so interesting if you
wanted to work at the stores they were
kind of genius so they'd have shutters
and you couldn't see what was inside and
when you went in there you had these
models and the models were told to be a
bit aloof not to sell they were kind of
like out of like like like kind of too
cool and they'd be like what can you
help me um i guess you have a size large
and be like i don't know do you see a
large
what
literally you'd be like i'll take it did
you ever rock any of that [ __ ] it was so
big when i was because i yeah i was like
at the height of it when i was in high
school so i met maybe i had one shirt
but yeah but it was expensive yeah
that's what i'm saying it was expensive
it was cool clothes also no i didn't i
couldn't get down with it i mean look
how i dressed my [ __ ] yeah now when
you were you know what i was like you
know it's a weird vibe yeah rocket chin
you rock
abercrombie i did
a lot you did yeah the shirts sweaters
yeah well y'all wait when did they come
out cause they popped when we were like
in high school and [ __ ] 2001 2002 so
that's when they came out
but no they came before that but even i
would say like late 90s early 2000s like
98 99 2000 they're the billion dollar
company
billion in sales you want to look like
those guys the guy said he goes every
gay man in the world has a copy of bruce
weber's book somewhere in their house
which was uh it was about it was
the pond with him let me call my best
friend yeah see if he has that bullet
yes you got that yeah but what's
interesting to that that photographer
got in trouble too because they had one
uh like their top model and he goes yeah
then bruce was like hey man i'm gonna
send a car to come pick you up and come
over for dinner and he's like nah i'm
good man
cause he wasn't gay he's like i'm cool
yeah and he's like yeah no doubt and
then they have the photos then i get a
call two minutes later he's like hey so
the car is there uh just come over and
he's like
no dude i have plans to my friends like
i'm gonna he's like bro he's like i'm
good man i'm good yeah he's over the
phone he goes literally a minute later i
get an email my flight and everything
they sent me home i got fired from the
company oh yeah
can you bring up you want to see the the
hot the diamond is the dime piece women
bring up heidi klum abercrombie and
pitch eddie klum was on there they she
was cute
they used huge snakes but it's weird
because they had like black people they
had black models
yeah
somewhat
like the choking guys but they oh it was
weird too they would all like a guy
they'd be like in a field and like dog
piling on each other it was so gay look
at her look at her oh back then dude
what even now
ferrari dude
yeah just keep
no they do they use
go back to them
what is this
that's abercrombie's [ __ ] magazine
but also he's got no clothes on what
does he have what are we selling what is
he selling okay i'd buy it you see what
brian
sorry
god how you claim is so hot though yeah
she's super nice
it's just so weird dude yeah it is look
at jennifer uh lawrence taylor
jennifer lawrence
uh
uh scarlett johansson was down there
asking kutcher there's so many i don't
know i don't know channing tatum was an
abercrombie model like so many famous
people
yep okay and there's that guy mike
jeffries down there who's mike jefferson
he was the he's the creator of this
thing he's a creator kind of a genius
he's the company over and he's a gay man
too yes but he's kind of a genius he
came up with the whole idea man what's
funny about him i think you know they're
like and we showed him we got him out of
there but then i
after i was after dollars later well the
settlement yeah he's the settlement i
think they have to pay him as far and
this is just what he got bought out of
his yeah because okay he had some
severance packages so he got like
37 million plus thirty seven dollars
yeah he's got awoke abercrombie so they
said he made a lot more money yeah what
do you say go to work abercrombie and
finish where's that at go down oh i
never knew that i one yeah that'd be
that'd be woke abercrombie oh
that's the new style
uh i guess so i guess that would be
considered uh what they think is the new
look and that's gonna sell clothing okay
okay
like all right yeah yeah that seems fake
because that that yeah i feel like that
shirt doesn't seem real i know but i
know they do do that now like if you
look at now they offer so it's so
complicated
so it's still doing good as a company i
guess no it's not no oh it's not they
bounce back a little bit but stock yeah
they're not doing great because of the
dock
uh even before that they became and the
the guy who was like the creative
director of all of it he goes i knew we
were kind of screwed when in the first
spider-man if you remember when
spider-man's getting beat up by a bully
he goes to hit him and spider-man has
those talents yeah he can't hit him he
was the bully he's like the the the bro
is from in head to toe about
he was i knew then we were [ __ ] wow
but i mean that's what it that's what it
evolved to yeah like the people that
rock that [ __ ] are like were
were [ __ ] now now that the company's
been they have a different leadership
and obviously you know they're more
inclusive and all that [ __ ] but now that
they have different leadership yeah i
think they're
kind of coming back but as far as kid
clothes go dude for my kids they have
some cute [ __ ] for kids
but you don't want you know after
watching that document i don't want to
[ __ ] yeah i wonder how yeah how they
evolved that style i mean what do you
got jen let's see what we got for cause
we got some cool
cool card events yeah yeah by the way so
abercrombie was kind of expensive but
there was like a brand beneath them i
think
it wasn't as expensive yeah yeah yeah
exactly that's cheap what are you
looking forward to selling a lifetime
oh but abercrombie yeah they owned
hollister
oh that's what it is i feel like the two
stores were just different vibes like
one was surfer huntington beach
california one's like
prestigious ivy league and they also
owned american eagle too
oh they're all the same
yeah yeah i bought a lot of american
evil stuff
what's up
so the girl bad baby the catch me
outside girl yeah
recently came out and said that she
doesn't like people referring to her as
the catch me outside girl anymore she'd
rather be known as bad baby or by her
name because she's created like i guess
a new name she's gotten away she's
reinvented herself is what she's saying
recently she bought a house in boca
raton for six point one million dollars
cash cash didn't she make 20 million
dollars on
uh she says that she made 50 million on
only fans in a year oh my god
granted is that yeah this isn't
confirmed because that's what she says
however yeah yeah she would have to
release the uh
proof herself however
she would do that she didn't make a
million dollars in less than 24 hours i
don't know that's the same yeah so then
she probably was on the yeah i i mean
she's like 60 million followers so her
reach is pretty well she might be i
don't think it's far from it
dude you know how much money you have to
pay
6 million in cash daddy
enough for her to move from la to fl
back to florida because taxes
making a good chunk of money regardless
whether it's 50 years good for her boca
raton's like really nice oh yeah
expensive too good for her for an older
car
yeah super old oh okay
straight up cash good for her for
parlaying that crazy [ __ ] on dr phil to
50 i know i know she's only 19. let's
say it's half let's
she's 19. that's crazy this is this is
so great amber heard looks like the
biggest [ __ ] so during the amber
heard and johnny depp trial amber
heard's lawyer talked about how she used
to carry around makeup to cover up the
bruises and they put up a very specific
type of makeup that is a color corrector
to kind of even out your skin tone
saying she used this all the time she
had it in her bag the makeup company
actually saw and said wait don't bring
us into this because your relationship
with johnny depp lasted from 2012 to
2016. this makeup product that you guys
are using as an example came out in
2017. oh whoa holy gentlemen
if you go down there's a tick tock yeah
she's not she's doing do you think she
made up she's great with god yeah you
think she made some [ __ ] you can expect
from me and that's the
huh
so the shawn she confirmed release 2017
wow damn
well
yeah she's kind of screwed she's she's
you can tell she's a bad horrible
y'all been watching it yeah oh yeah have
you ever dude hillary it's tough to
watch baldwin go bad on her she's like
blah blah [ __ ] blah using your victim
womanhood to be a victim and and she
goes she's basically a terrible person
yeah yeah those recordings are intense
so and she goes i hope uh johnny depp is
gonna make nine more pipes of the
caribbean yeah she came out and goes no
more she saw an opportunity to up her
profile at his expense because she's
just one of those [ __ ] sociopaths
terrible person i can tell yeah oh jen
do you have a current event that twitter
selling to elon it's happening
yeah no it already did yeah so it's in
the process
they agreed to it they accepted it i
think i think
so eventually first of all it says near
selling but then it says like
they reached a deal
i mean 50 54 a share three percent
premium so he paid whatever 30 or 44
billion something crazy yeah
yeah so i wonder what's so i know you
know he free speech but he's going to
regulate
obviously twitter now
if you know the misinformation as they
say it which is really far-right news
that you know right now twitter's
getting rid of that
but i know i think elon's going to get
rid of some of that far-right stuff and
also far like he's just not gonna let
far left fly well there's a doesn't it
the main thing is
having foreign actors so so for example
eleven percent they found out of the
support for amber heard is fake it's
it's bots oh wow it's not real that that
came out eleven percent so let's get rid
of that johnny depp is getting a massive
amount 89
of love no johnny depp is getting all
the love and yeah there's there's a
little bit trying to make it seem like
there's a little bit of yeah i think
eleven percent of the of the entire
thing is like and the the sorry is
getting some
like support it's it's not real
yeah it's not real people but then that
that other let's say
rogan posted it that other nine percent
is coming from who though amber herb's
team
no no no no so what they think is it's
foreign actors who who who do this to
create division in our country so any
anything you see that becomes vaccines
mass they want chaos
yeah
do you think elon brings trump back onto
twitter and no yes yeah
why wouldn't you because that
is because if
trump he's just free speech why would we
kick the foreign president united states
off now if he gets on there starts
talking [ __ ] about vaccines that's not
backed by science or starts spreading
crazy [ __ ]
no
they're still gonna monitor that but
he'll have a platform he's not going to
not let him on
yeah you have to if that's why elaine
buys it and you want
free speech you have to have them on
there yeah it's like keep that same
energy yeah and keep that same right
also trump you know politics i get
polarizing he had some hilarious tweets
like his tweet about diet coke
i didn't see that because he drinks so
many diet cokes and he got on there goes
hey i'm just caught like i see it i've
never seen a skinny person drink diet
coke only fat people drink diet coke and
then literally two minutes ago whoa
getting a lot of [ __ ] for that diet coke
tweet
damn
he's like everybody drinks all cokes you
know like backtracked it's so funny
there is a video of someone trying to
summon their tesla i didn't know this
was a new feature but you can
make your tesla come to you by summoning
it and as long as you have kind of a
clear path towards you the tesla will
follow and never use it in and out of
things that are in its way there is a
video of someone's tesla crashing into a
three million dollar jet because it
couldn't
weave its way around trying to summon
itself too but also what dude what a
rich person problem yeah yeah try try
relaying this to your how's your day
going do you believe this [ __ ] man my
[ __ ] test i put i sent it into my it
ran it ran my [ __ ] baby dude now i
have to fight against partially you
believe this man i get another one i
have to fly commercial
you want to see it yeah please
[Music]
oh it's super sick
oh oh oh oh it keeps going yeah oh
i i don't trust anything oh so it just
moved it yeah it didn't look that bad
right now i thought i thought that whole
like [ __ ] that's a super small jet
that's hilarious though
yeah i bet you i bet he had some chicken
and he's bragging like watching this
she's all white what the [ __ ]
hilarious
oh wow god first world problems your
[ __ ] cars crashing your private jet
hilarious you know it's it also looks
like you damaged maybe the back wheel
and the tesla so i'm sure it's not i
heard an artificial intelligence expert
say that we are
10 years away from really ai it's really
hard
we're not
terrible though not as close yeah
terrible yeah a lot of people think it's
here already but it's oh we're still 10
away
all right maybe i'm wrong maybe he's
wrong
so aziz ansari is currently on set for
his new film where he's trying to make a
comeback post his cancellation and bill
murray is among the cast
when i guess there was a situation where
an inappropriate conduct
was reported to the heads uh they shot
production now because
did he make out did he make a joke that
was sexual innovation
no
uh if it was a sexual allegation i think
they would have said i think it's just
because he has a history of being
difficult to work with and kind of yeah
but have you heard all the actors coming
out and now they're telling these
horrible bill murray stories there was
one side also you're like holy [ __ ] i
had no clue wait so they were just
saying he's being mean they didn't say
this particular set they did not release
what was said or what was done but
people are saying based off of his track
record that he probably blew up on
someone that he has a history of having
it's with women in uh groping oh almost
positive you research because now it's
out how old is this
this was yesterday i saw yeah i saw i
read something i think on new york post
this morning they came out and said it's
because of inappropriate times oh wow
but what's weird is like people that
he's worked with before like when he did
groundhog day would argue his best movie
his best friend was the director
they had a uh
a different opinion on creative on some
scene they got a straight up fight fight
like he choked him oh really and they
never they did they were best friends
they didn't talk for like 30 years and
just recently like that i think i was
like on his deathbed and bill murray
made up with him
and bill murray and chevy chase got a
straight up fist fight on the set of
silent live him and lucy lou did the
same thing on charlie's angels they had
to be physically separated i want yeah
this looks like this a set member
continued like one guy said he was very
physical sometimes he put his arm around
a woman sometimes he would pull
touch her hair pull her ponytail but
always in a funny way it's a fine line
everyone loves bill but while his
behavior isn't banned it's made some
women uncomfortable and he definitely
crossed the line it sounds like a guy an
older guy who has an older world and
that's what it is and now it's like they
change the rules so
yeah he loves women likes to flirt
enjoys poetry and romance he was awesome
i was more surprised co-stars came out
and said how much of a dick you was on
set that sucks
i've heard nothing it's weird because
he's always he he seems to always just
keep doing so
i've always heard good things from
people that worked with him always yeah
it's where all these people are coming
out with these horror stories like [ __ ]
dude yeah
yeah that sucks
all righty what else you got
got to be honest they're not the best
here but all right oh let's check this
out real quick this
police officer the way he handled this
situation was incredible so i'll just
show you the video for yeah
oklahoma city
hold on a second let me see if i can so
that video i know it sucks dude
let me take off take off the ad blocker
there it goes yeah let's watch a
commercial first and then
just let mike tyson think
yeah thanks
all right here we go
passing tens nearly struck a
ocpd
motorcycle officer on the inside
so this officer is
chasing someone who has who's a robbery
suspect with a gun any chp
highway patrol
and the guy's shooting at the officer
puts he in
sorry shot him there looks like a land
rover range rover
he's [ __ ] taken off he shot one
through the back window
he's just so chill which i know right
incredible yeah
he's still pointing the gun
[Applause]
now
and he's so calm on the
walkie-talkie this guy's
this guy's nuts
is he trying to ram him off yeah yeah
just super dangerous because they're
really not supposed to do this because
oh [ __ ] ducks again how is he he's lucky
he's not dead dude yeah he doesn't go
[ __ ] that just captain america right
i wonder what that means
good question brian what's the guy so
chill yeah
this guy went nowhere that guy's done
and where's his homies though how's
nobody cut off the yeah right
where's the helicopter
that's what i was thinking i was like
no other officers that showed up
yeah whatever i thought he said tdi oh
he might have said td huh
[Music]
something to do with him like getting
him off the road yeah like hitting him
interesting it was dope wow
i don't know i mean there's a shot
there's a guy shooting he's shooting we
are going a hundred miles shot at me
again i mean i'm really flying here i
got it you know so that was almost like
whoa that was close
[Laughter]
so i'm sure you guys have all seen this
video guy was such an [ __ ] yeah so
some guy was like harassing mike tyson
on a plane it looked like he was in
first class too yeah he was just drunk
apparently they took a picture with mike
before they got on the plane mike took
it her mic was nice to him yeah i do
cool and the guy kept talking mike i
guess mike turner was like hey man
i'm i'm gonna like shut it down be cool
man i'll give you your time and then the
guy kept harassing him yeah apparently
the guy has a long lengthy he does have
a huge uh yeah a pretty bad oh he's like
a restaurant he's a [ __ ] yeah a complete
piece of [ __ ] yeah also his face looks
like you want a pumpkin right dude when
he yeah especially the ending of it when
he's like looking like um
he's punching him right here obviously
tmz reports that tyson began hitting the
man who was see seated behind him what
is up with this guy he's just crazy man
from california but he's also like
like this this footage right here i'm
like what are you doing dude i mean
apparently was incredible yeah that
makes you want to punch him look yeah
like that does dude
why is he making that face he's so
punchable
yeah
i wonder what happens to mike hopefully
nothing i hope no other guy didn't press
trump i didn't press any charges or
anything yeah
so i saw joe rogan post this which
sounded insane it's real yeah it's real
well this is a vice
so i trust vice yeah but apparently
there's like an issue in india where
sometimes people
have sex with animals i don't think it's
india i think human beings are crazy
maybe a monitor lizard this particular
one poor men there's this particular
people in the world all over the world
in america in india and everywhere who
will do the craziest [ __ ] you can so we
keep going to what happens sounds like
they were drunk and they were doing it
on a dare
something like that but the fact that
they all gang raped this monitor lizard
that's protected like i guess there's
like only a few left over it was a
common moderately i know it's a little
it's still terrible but yeah
but then they killed it and then eight
and they ate it afterwards you gotta
[ __ ] them and then eat them yeah and
then we have the pictures
you're a little too cool for these
oh these are the guys yeah so okay it
says right here in this article the
yellow the red the blue and the very far
right these guys are great look at this
what
you [ __ ] the lizard huh did you [ __ ]
it gang raped it killed it was like
it's crazy that they [ __ ] was it a
cult ritual yeah
no no no no no no they're just [ __ ]
losers i don't buy it
i buy every part of it i don't think
they [ __ ] it
yeah i don't know but i mean so it says
82 cases of sexual abuse against 10
years yeah
500 000 this is this is a real article
this is on vice
and joe rogan posted when i saw i was
like what the freak is they were they
were accused i need to see i need to go
through the trial i think i'm set i
think these guys are [ __ ] weird ryan
needs to see the video
yeah i don't know but i mean it's just a
crazy crazy story i got skeptical hippo
eyes oh i don't yeah those guys suck
okay okay hey you can't just say that no
you're just looking at them yeah yeah
just got sucked look
guilty
i mean
it's a weird story though bad detective
though no i'm i mean i see what you
don't you know
you're just deciding that they suck but
you didn't even know who it was it could
be the guys on the side no
i'm kind of skeptical of this too
hold on those guys you don't like those
guys the yellow the red
[ __ ] killed a lizard yeah
it could be a lie
i'm gonna assume that journalists did
their [ __ ] job i'm gonna assume he
didn't really no they're investigating
right now that's what he's doing
it
they're saying they [ __ ] goats and stuff
too so you've brought this up before
look human beings have [ __ ] a lot of
animals but i don't think you ever look
at a monster lizard and go i'm gonna i
know yeah that's the [ __ ] food that's
why it's headlines
let's go that's gonna work your
ding-a-ling it sounds like it's you know
what it says to me like they are it's so
gross it's so nice somebody was joking
around put their dick on it and said
look my dick looks like a lizard that's
what it sounds like and then they were
like you guys [ __ ] the lizards that you
don't know that there's a person i've
been dead [ __ ] going on
oh no i oh no i think these four guys
were in india and caught a lizard and
then [ __ ] and raped it brian killed it
you can't just like they said you can't
just say that chin zoom in the guy in
red
zoom in on that guy how does that good
policeman much
zoom in on the guy and i'll make my
choice do me a little guy on the right
um stay open keep your mind open now let
me try again they're all dressed like
brian jean's insane i know they've got
this okay
now hold on hold on
hold on
i mean now that guy
hold on here's a i can zoom in now
all right hold on
what do you think no hold on that guy
[ __ ] lizards
but only that guy he's wearing a polo
shirt that's an expensive polo shirt
dude apparently this is yellow is this a
pack guy definitely
what's up is this a picture of them in
custody or something no what is this
this is a picture of them like they they
it's like before identified these four
people were the ones that did it i don't
know how they did it but who's squealing
lizard well he did too it was just like
village talk how do you see him look i'm
not even in that picture if they're
taking that picture i'm not even in that
picture as a cop i'm gonna be like i'm
covering my face just so nobody thinks
what is this picture i don't understand
this this is this is just a picture of
them for yeah
the group of people actually did it this
guy this guy and this guy did it here's
a group of them with
other friends family or before dinner
there's a gun i don't know it's india
dude
it's a crazy story but yeah good way to
end the podcast i'll tell you that
i still got skeptical hippo eyes um
you're a believer i don't know if i buy
it yeah i buy it for fred brown's a
believer one more so this is for bry
sportscenter posted this it's about uh
yeah the thing that brian likes
it looks pretty crazy it is pretty crazy
how they yeah intense the rally
[Music]
[Music]
with that sport whatever that was
actually a cool video that was a cool
video that's as cool as that's gonna get
that's as cool as that's gonna get i'd
rather see the video of the monitor list
see you this weekend
vegas everybody wise guys
you've been you've done that club yeah
yeah it's great club uh thursday the
only thing that matters thursday
uh on think boy youtube the gringo poppy
special drops and then along with a
special tomorrow at 9 00 a.m tuesday
april 26th on thinkboy.com we're
dropping the gringo poppy shirts for the
special we're dropping the
thick boy fight club shirts hoodies
the thick boy uh trucker hats that's all
available on thinkboy.com at 9 00 a.m
tomorrow also for those of you on
thursday that watch the special we're
doing a giveaway use the hashtag the
gringo poppy the most creative picture
post on instagram my team's gonna search
through it for the our fave our favorite
five are gonna get a signed uh thick boy
gringo poppy uh
cover signed cover and then also uh a
bottle of tiger thick whiskey our five
favorite and then we're giving out 200
signed posters to the other people that
uh do it so use the hashtag the gringo
poppy and those will be mailed out next
week special drops this mother trucking
thursday outside that the album drops
thursday with chin thick boy album
little brows created this we got jelly
roll on it chappelle's on it here
griffin crystalia bert kreischer uh mike
stud
it's posted
yeah they're postings on it i didn't
know that old school dear people oh wow
derek's on there and that drops on
thursday as well on spotify itunes
amazon apple music wherever you listen
to music and charlotte may 5th through
the 7th come get some comedy zone
charlotte north carolina and then also
philadelphia's may 19th through 21st
tickets at thickboy.com
oh yeah bry uh las vegas number this
weekend thursday friday saturday new
brunswick new jersey stress factory may
5 7. i am then at the dc comedy law of
may 12th 13th 14th
bray improv special taping may 19th with
a very special guest opening for me
and uh
this should be great
see you then
boom may
6th and 7th i'll be in san diego at mike
drop comedy club may 12th i'll be doing
a one-nighter at a stand-up live in
phoenix and then uh later on the summer
june 24th and 25th i'll be in uh rhode
island at comedy connection
that's it kids we love you enjoy the
special hope you guys enjoy it hopefully
i made you proud
drops this thursday love you we're out